i mean look he's the kind of guy just
just understand the psychology right
he's the kind of guy where if
you know if he thought and again i'm not
saying this is what happened i'm saying
just talking his perspective if he
thought he'd be beaten fair and square
he'd say all right and he'd you know
he'd pack up he'd go home but if he
thought something was stolen from him
right if he thought something was taken
away from him then does he really seem
like the kind of guy that's just going
to let that happen is going to let that
slide of course not no he's going to be
the guy who's going to want to get back
in and take back what he
in you know right or wrong views as
something that is rightfully his
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former navy intelligence officer the
senior editor at human events and the
author of the new children's book i've
got it right in my hand right now the
island of free ice cream jack pasovic
welcome to the reuben report dave i am
so excited and i just can't hide it
we're going to talk all about the fact
that there's no such thing as free ice
cream today
you know i've known you we met once in
person you've done the show once before
but i know you mostly through twitter
and if you would have said to me a
couple of years ago you think jack
besobiak is going to write a children's
book i'm pretty sure i would not have
had that on my list but at this point at
this point
where we're at in the world it's like
pretty much anything's possible this is
proof of that i think
yeah you know and they reached out to me
so it's it's with brave books
and they have the whole thing up at
brave books so it's it's like ashley
sinclair and elizabeth johnston and
there's some other big names actually i
think they just announced it so i can
say this now that dan crenshaw is the uh
is going to be the next one coming out
with a book um
you know that was something we were like
don't say it yeah we're still you know
you know getting the ink is just getting
dry everything etc etc but um yeah we
can announce that now and what it really
is is look when you walk into and and
it's a big thing for me too right you
mentioned a couple years ago well a
couple years ago i wasn't a father right
i didn't have my own kids right i wasn't
looking at life
differently i was just it's go go go man
hey you go back even you know 10 years
i'm in the navy i'm i'm deploying i'm
doing this i'm doing that you know i'm
not thinking about that stuff i'm
thinking about me right yeah right it's
it's it's when you're younger your life
is more centered on yourself that's just
how we are that's that's human nature
but you know as you get older
and then we do have kids and you start
thinking more socially being more
socially minded more broadly minded more
you know you have a more of a widespread
outlook on life and you start to think
well wait a minute what about what's
going on here what's going on there how
are we doing this how are we doing and
when you walk into one of these
you know commercial bookstores lately at
books amelia and barnes noble i swear
it's like the first book i see it's
always this table that's set out and
it's children's books and every single
one of the authors their last names is
either a biden obama clinton or a harris
right mina harris the niece and so i'm
saying wow this is just it's so
politicized and i don't remember that i
mean you know my kids books were like
the last name was soos you know like
it's just basic
you know you mean that old racist right
you can't right
you can't even do that you know i'm
learning like one fish two fish um and
now we're talking about all this really
politicized stuff and so i said look
there's been this idea on the right
that
you know it was always like it's always
like well the campus crazies will just
stay on campus because then they'll go
to real life and they'll get mugged by
reality to use the the old buckley in
line and then they'll stop and they'll
go back to normal and everything will be
fine right well that's not what happened
the campus crazies followed into the
corporate crazies the military crazies
the academia crazies all the crazies
right everywhere and so that's now
filtering into where into schools right
pre-k through 12. and of course this is
happening we see trt etc etc and the
books are a huge part of this so the
right
has been playing this game or even not
even just the right but people who just
believe in you know traditional values
basic american values totally seated
this space just totally seeded the space
and said oh it'll correct itself it's
self-correcting don't worry this isn't
some big thing guess what folks it is so
that's why we decided to put this
together they reached out to me and they
said do you want to do something i'm
like i don't know like what should i
write about and they're like what are
you they're like what's something that
you don't like and i said communism
right you know
and they said well we just so happens
that we have a book that we think that
would lend itself to that so we kind of
work together on the writing of it and
it's it's it's actually got and this is
the one thing i said to them i was like
look i don't want to do one of those big
preachy things where it's some story and
then all of a sudden you know jack
pasobic walks over and is like well kids
let's talk today about the virtues of
the free market and miltonian milton
friedman and ein rand like no no no like
that i don't want to do that stuff right
so uh they showed me the storyboards on
and i said this is actually really cool
like this is a book
there's characters they're like on an
island there's a marketplace but then
you know some wolves show up and they
say hey come to our island we've got
free ice cream you know and this guy's
trying to not only i'm gonna illustrate
the island here there's a giant
it comes
with a big map i think i got it right
here
oh my gosh yeah look at this right so
what the weight is we'll put up a still
so that i'm not so foldy here
i know right so yeah though so the way
it works is with the whole series
and there's 12 in the first saga there's
going to be more sagas so it's like you
get one a month and then each one of the
books corresponds with one of those
circles and the different places that
are on that map are different stories
and they all kind of interlock i mean
you can read them out of order i think
makes sense as long as it's in the saga
but um each story kind of feeds into the
other one as sort of a shared you know
like marvel universe kind of idea
but you know for kids that are reading
it and you know my son's three so i
showed him some of the story boards and
he's like oh cool sheep and wolves like
like he kind of knows that wolves are
like bad and sheep are good but he
doesn't really have you know like you
know ice and he knows ice cream is good
he gets that right naturally that one's
that's that's pretty basic um but he
doesn't understand so much the total
plots yet but he can at least get the
action of it right so they go to the
island of the wolves and guess what
turnout spoiler alert right it's not
very good on the island of free ice
cream it's actually quite bad and you
can't get out and there's like this
berlin wall surrounding it so it's like
a cuba east germany china kind of place
and um
anyway so that's kind of the story but
there's a lot of action to it and it's
interesting and then you get to talk
about some of these ideas and at the end
there is a little bit more of like that
whole educator piece where you know
we're working with like homeschool
groups we're working with religious
groups we're looking with a lot of
people who just want to check out of the
system and say look we are not on board
with where you guys are going but we
need to find something to replace all of
this woke junk with and i said look
that's that's where brave books comes in
so it's actually really cool
you know you can start to have those
discussions like okay you know it yeah i
wish things were free too right wouldn't
that be great would wouldn't it be
awesome to live in the world of star
trek the next generation where there's a
replicator and you can walk over and you
know i've got my earl grey tea right but
we don't live in that world and so maybe
when somebody and it's just the basic
idea right that when someone offers you
something that seems too good to be true
it probably is it probably is now the
real question is at the libraries will
this book be recommended by the drag
queens during drag queen story hour are
they going to be handing out this book i
might be able to sneak it in i don't
know maybe while maybe while they're
getting all the attention we'll just be
running around the back like throwing
them all over the place
so i mean i'm super impressed by this
because one of the things i've been
talking about on the show for a while is
i'm sort of tired of people that just
talk and i want to find people that
build and people that do and that's why
it's very cool to me that you were like
yeah i will write a children's book
about these ideas because we got to fix
all of this stuff but i wanted to read
the the mission statement by brave
they're the publishers of the book i
thought this was pretty great
timeless virtues for a new generation a
progressive agenda is dominating today's
culture and teaching our kids all the
wrong lessons that's why we created a
book series geared towards children ages
4 to 12. each month we will release a
new story which teaches a foundational
conservative value so you already hit on
this but do you think that's where we're
at as a society at this point that
depending on what your political beliefs
are you're literally going to have
different children's books you're going
to have different schools you are going
to have different businesses ultimately
different tech and just you know as far
down the road as you want to run that
concept
well it's really interesting because you
know and i know you talk about this a
lot that a lot of this started with
relativism and the idea that there are
no you know absol there's no good
there's no bad there's just it's it's
what was the phrase that seeped into our
culture it's not the truth it's my truth
and your truth
and it's like whoa wait wait if we can't
agree on basic facts and we can't agree
on basic morality then what's going to
happen right this is exactly what
happens because of that because we took
away objective morality in society right
we took that away we rejected it we
replaced it with what was nothing right
and we tried to do that for a while but
it didn't work but then up along comes
this new ideology and says we are the
new morality we are social morality the
government has essentially replaced god
in in this sort of this like inverted
hierarchy and then so the the the
leading purveyors of the government the
bureaucrats the experts you know they
are they are the high priests and the
acolytes et cetera et cetera
and so
these books then seek to impose that new
morality right on our kids and and it's
it's a false reality in many ways but
also because it just doesn't line up
with people's lives it doesn't line up
with reality it doesn't line up with
human nature and so people who
read this stuff at a young age are set
up with false expectations for how their
lives are going to be and it is not
going to work out you are not going to
get success and so that's why the true
test of a of an actual moral system is
does it work right does if i follow
these precepts will i succeed will i
find happiness will i find
self-actualization right as as thomas
aquinas wrote years ago um you know
these are the basic understandings of
what should underpin you know hey
immoral ideology and yet when you look
at the left the people who follow it
they're some of the most curmudgeonly uh
miserable nasty people in the world it's
just just just terrible and i feel like
they don't look that good either
no no there's a reason for that i
believe it's like um you know it's like
in star wars when the emperor is using
the dark side and he uh you know
and corrupts his appearance right and i
never liked how they changed that where
they said it was just the lightning i
always liked this idea that you know he
was using the eve the force for evil and
then so that created a negative you know
side of him like that was sort of the
what was going on in the originals but
then you know then they had to throw
that out and say no no it's just a
blaster from a lightsaber it's like oh
no you actually had a had a really good
story there but then you you decided
that wasn't as marketable as just you
know being able to sell new toys i know
that the two of us could do like an
eight-hour show on star wars and the
disaster that it's become but i'm i'm
actually funny enough because we're
talking kids books i decided um
my house is going to be star wars free
for my kids
only star wars
wait so you wouldn't even do the
originals for them and just say cut it
off at that or
i'm big on the prequels but you wouldn't
even go that far no no because the way i
look at it now is
the originals for as much as i liked
them when i was growing up they're just
a gateway drug into the rest of you
right and so that they hook you they
hook you like a drug dealer right right
so lucasfilm is the go is the drug
dealer they say hey look at these movies
they're so great they're so good and
then you come in and then you you know
by the time you get to the woke awakens
or whatever the next one that comes out
is you're like wait where am i this is
not where i started and you even
actually had marsha lucas which i
thought was amazing marcia lucas who was
the original editor of star wars and
empire the ex-wife of george lucas after
he divorced or he kind of writes her out
of the story
um you know the force is female right
what about marcia lucas not so much um
and so she comes out and says these
aren't movies these are made by people
who have no idea what what star wars is
there's no morality what is this there's
like some girl who shows up and she just
has force powers because and then it's
never really explained she's a clone
well no she's not a clone she's the
daughter of a clone and that makes sense
for some reason she said that after she
watched the prequels she went into her
car and cried because it could have been
so good and we ended up getting what we
got and so i i might i think i don't
think you mean the prequels there i
think you mean the last three not the
prequels you mean the last three years
oh she cried after the prequels too
after seeing the phantom menace yeah
ah but that was that was at least lucas
you know
right but that's the thing is the
original star wars movies were made by
sort of a committee in a sense right
where um
you know lucas sort of came up with this
you know he took elements of course from
like dune and flash gordon and these you
know joseph campbell this idea of the
mono myth um the hero's journey right
and so he's picking all that together
and then he had some of the names right
he had some of that stuff together but
it was really uh
gary kurtz and marsha lucas on the
editing side and a bunch of people that
were brought in by fox that said hey
george we're going to take your story
that um he was trying to do this whole
vietnam war thing and like make it this
like very like top heavy kind of like
really heady material kind of deal and
said they're like yeah we're just gonna
make this like good guys versus bad guys
george so
you know i know you don't like that and
he was like oh you guys know what you're
talking about so well we're just going
to go in a little bit of a different
direction
well look
i assume this is going to do extremely
well so your obvious next move is it
will be the next star wars
bigger than star wars yeah altogether
all right moving on from star wars for
just a second uh there's a lot going on
in the world look i thought that by this
is there is there's some news it's been
so boring here in d.c
oh right you're in dc too we should talk
about that but look i thought it was
going to be a disaster so i'm really not
surprised by any of this i suppose if
i'm surprised at any level it would just
be like how quickly everything became
awful but the general awful state i'm
not surprised by
where do you grade this thing at the
moment i mean just as we're starting
this biden just said that 98 of us have
to be vaccinated otherwise we'll never
get back to normal as he was getting his
booster shot from the vaccine that he
said if you got in the first place that
you know we'd all be okay with
yeah that's actually right and and i'll
i'll break a little news on here um and
i'll hold this back peek from uh you
know from twitter and everything else
before before we can do this because
actually just as you and i were
preparing to get on here in the pre-show
i got a text in from
someone who is a currently serving u.s
official at the white house who said
that statement that number that 98 came
from a briefing from dr fauci about a
week ago that was being had and my
question is if i would go back to that
briefing and i'll respond to them after
this and say
it was that talking about herd immunity
because i remember the last time i heard
this herd immunity was like 75 80
was the idea and that also that hurt
immunity should include people like
myself who have natural immunity because
i had real covid i had like knocked me
on my butt i'm eating vietnamese pho for
a week and watching like bad tv shows
because my you know i'm just like half
tired half asleep the whole time i mean
it sucked like it's definitely not the
flu right um but you know i i ate fun
and a bunch of like sprite and i'm fine
right i'm totally fine it's like a year
ago and so i've still yet to have
somebody come to me and make the
convincing argument as to why natural
immunity shouldn't count right and i
think there's a huge portion of the
population that is also wondering
wondering about this plus you also used
to have and glenn greenwald's talked
about this that the aclu used to be one
of the leading organizations talking
against
vaccine mandates because they actually
pointed out that fact that pushing
vaccine mandates from a higher level
actually drives vaccine hesitancy
because what is it right it's the hammer
not the it's not the hammer not the cat
right it's it's it's like it's you're
you're demanding people do it so you're
going to initiate you know there's going
to be a certain number of people that
say well i'm not going to do it just
because you say i have to why should i
right you know and it's
of course the u.s government hasn't ever
done anything dave that would call into
question their trustworthiness and their
veracity with the american people
i've never heard of anything i don't
know what you could possibly no no i
couldn't possibly it couldn't possibly
be but are you somewhat shocked that if
if we were to question any of this stuff
like i'm very aware of this on twitter
if we're to question any the veracity of
the vaccine whether it's working or not
actually as you know because i think you
were the probably the first guy i texted
the day before i went off the grid
last day of july
again what was the tweet in essence i
said that vaccine mandates are coming
and they don't want you to know that
and and i was banned from twitter
twitter later said it was an error but
i'm pretty sure i got that one right um
but
this this there's like a month ago right
this is hilarious it was it was july
31st yeah a couple months ago okay
yeah give or take a month yeah um so you
tweet out that you think essentially it
looks like vaccine mandates are coming
banned on twitter right right locked out
was it 12 hours
12 hours and then i had to delete the
tweet otherwise they put you in they put
you in perpetual with no answer as to
when you might come back if you're
refusing to put your penalty box for 12
hours then they make you take the tweet
down which which by the way you know
we're talking about communism in the
book but this is
in mao's china the idea of
self-incrimination
right is big right they could delete the
tweet for you right i always bring this
up with people they could delete the
tweet for you but as part of your
struggle session you have to admit your
crime you have to admit your thought
crime you know you have to admit i was a
capitalist i was an exploitative
landlord i spoke out against the great
leap forward right you have to admit
that and only if you believe to your
struggle session this is the key people
understand they use that free struggle
session you're not struggling against
the people you're struggling against
your past self and the idea that you're
purifying yourself into the new ideology
so i always think about that when they
make you delete the tweet yourself
there's something very insidious about
that and the fact that it actually is a
form of making you incriminate your own
thoughts and your own words but the fact
is that you said this was coming and i
remember the tweet the way you had
worded it was like you think this is
coming not like you know i can prove
this is coming and yet
here we are talking about 98
people are about to be kicked out of the
military there's that
you know the great account libs of tick
tock um has and they're not just doing
libs anymore it's really just sort of
like a tick tock news kind of site now
uh and military members and we covered
this on on human events daily just today
that there's an e4 in the air force
saying look i don't want to take this
i'm about to be kicked out i've signed
up i've gone through all my training
here are my qualifications can you guys
help me find a job right so we're
purging our military on the basis of
this think about who we're purging by
the way are health care workers so many
they're in new york state they're
talking about bringing in the national
guard to backfill health care workers
i'm sorry i thought this whole thing was
supposed to be help remember two weeks
to stop the spread right lower the curve
so that we can help icus because of the
capacity and because of bringing the
burden down on healthcare workers if
this is about health why are you firing
the health care workers right so it
literally we went in a year and a half
we went from two weeks to flatten the
curve to we're firing nurses in the name
of health which i don't know that we've
had any sort of mass outbreak by nurses
or within our military or anything like
that but but what what do you think this
really gets to in that it's not stopping
i mean this is what i'm trying to
explain to people it doesn't matter if
everyone's vaccinated or everyone stays
home or everyone wears masks the
governments and i mean governments not
just ours but australia canada i mean
we're just watching western governments
commit harry carey and take down their
people at the same time that's what it
seems like to me that they they're just
loving rampaging through everyone's
rights and very few of us are doing
anything this will
stop
when
the citizenry
decides it should stop um
you know russ dohat in the new york
times and i don't really cite the new
york times very often but he he had a
pretty provocative headline on an op-ed
about a week ago and he said what if
covid was was 10 times more deadly right
what if kovid was 10 times more deadly
and i'm like
well if kovet was 10 times more deadly
that i'd probably be on board with a lot
of this stuff right i think that would
make sense don't give them any good
ideas jeff no no no but but here's
here's what i'm getting at here's what
i'm getting at because i'm not
i i want to make a point is is that
we have a situation where we know that
it's not we know that there are people
it's it's look it's been what a year and
a half i was one of the first people
that said you know all the way back
january 2020 let's add china to the
travel ban we can't allow those flights
to come in why are we still doing this
we can see what's going on in wuhan we
can see they're trying to shut it down
just stop the flights just do it just
stop the flights
we were doing podcasts about it back
then they're like oh you're crazy or
xenophobic etc etc i said no it's about
a virus that comes from there i don't
care that it is there but it is to deal
with it um we know everything that's
come out since then about that and the
lab and what they don't want us to know
etc etc but
i think the key thing
in this is that you have a situation now
where people are going to say look
we can look at this as as independent
critical thinking individuals and know
that okay people with comorbidities you
got to take care of them people who are
seniors right they're high at risk you
got to take care of them people who have
the immunodeficiency i i was just down
in florida uh meeting with a friend of
mine who had gone through um he's had
he's just getting over throat cancer
right he's he's walks around double mast
all the time that makes sense right
because he gets that he's done he's
going to be wiped out like his system
will not be able to handle that right
that makes sense for his position but
the idea that we are going to allow
government to have all this power
they're never going to give it away and
you know there are some people who said
well you know i think this is just it's
a one-time thing
medical tyranny medical tyranny is the
future
right this is never going to stop
because medicine in our technology our
biotechnology is only getting better and
better our government systems are only
becoming more and more advanced you're
seeing the union now of government with
silicon valley so with technology you
tie in the biomedical aspect of that and
look if you ever watch that movie
gattica from 1997 it's happening man
five years ago
i think it was it was andrew nichols and
ethan hawk and jude law and uma thurman
and i think they just nailed it you have
two classes of people you have the
valids and the invalids and we are
rapidly very rapidly running to a
society like that so what do you think
is the driver of this you're a bit of an
expert on what's going on in china i
mean is china did china release this and
then basically convinced all of our
governments to destroy themselves is
that really the driver like why is it
that every time i open up twitter i have
videos of australian police officers and
and members of the army literally
choking their own citizens in the name
of health or canada closing churches or
all of the nonsense that we see here
every day
so the the analysis you know with my
sort of you know putting on my china
analyst hat here for a minute um
you know looking at the ccp
uh they are terrified of anything that
slows down their growth and you can look
at their response to the contagion of or
potential contagion of evergrand which
is one of their largest real estate
developers possibly going down uh
through a very similar subprime market
you know situation as the u.s saw during
the credit crunch in 2007 2008 uh watch
the movie the big short you know if one
wants to know more about that uh china
same situation right they overheated
this they overheated this they fueled it
with that fueled it with debt um but
what's interesting is a lot of the the
money a lot of the investments that
china was using actually come from u.s
pension funds why because you have
organizations like blackrock and
blackstone that are putting u.s dollars
u.s money into chinese investments right
in china so one interesting thing that
china is doing right now in the ccp is
they're bailing out these firms
partially where they're only bailing out
the
the chinese liability side of it but
with the for the us because a lot of
these are joint ventures
for the u.s side they're letting the
contagion spread it's the exact same
situation that we saw with covet 19. and
uh somebody actually had an analysis
that was pretty pretty provocative
in relation to the wuhan lab and they
were wondering is it possible because
we're now seeing all these variants
right there's all these different
variants coming out and you know this
variant that variant but we don't really
know where the first variant was right
because we don't have the data
internally when it comes to china so we
just sort of arbitrarily started naming
these with the greek alphabet and so
some people have
suggested that what if you know in those
crazy videos coming out of china early
on like what was people knocking you
know falling down and stuff and so the
theory was
is it possible that the original variant
of this thing was actually a lot worse
right is it possible that that variant
was a lot worse that's what was knocking
down people in wuhan and some of the
other cities but then it was a mutation
of it that got out and so with my ccp
analyst hat on and i'm looking at xi
jinping and i'm thinking look he doesn't
want a slowdown in china because of one
or two percent unemployment taking in
the united states okay that's a couple
hundred thousand people a couple hundred
thousand people there here there et
cetera et cetera you do the stimulus
statements
one to two percent
unemployment in china is a revolution
right that you know you've got a
revolution on your hands and every
chinese dynasty and you can think of the
ccp as a dynasty has gone through what's
called the theory of dynastic uh decline
and so they go through this cycle where
the dynasty is doing well it's it's it's
risen then the dynasty becomes corrupt
and this goes thousands of years right
and then dynasty becomes corrupt they
lose what's called the mandate of heaven
and one of the ideas
uh that they see as an omen or a
precursor of losing the mandate of
heaven is famine
pestilence and disease so that's why
very early on ccp
uh of course the you know they're an
atheist organization they're not they're
not they're not christian they're not
believers one of the first things they
said was this disease is a virus from
hell a demon from hell why did they
specifically use that language because
they were framing themselves as being on
the side of heaven and the demon is
being on the side of hell that's that's
that goes back to this sort of like this
this this idea of the theory of domestic
decline and so
i think really what their what the
thought was was
all right we have this thing inside
china we know that it's circulating we
know that it's mutating we know that bad
things are happening why should we be
the only ones who take the hit why
shouldn't the rest of the world have to
take the hit too
so then do you think they're thrilled
watching these western nations do to
their citizens what they're doing i mean
that they're we're helping them do it
right whatever it is that they want to
do
absolutely i mean you know and it's it's
like howard bloom wrote in lucifer
principle that you know this idea that
every every nation is a sort of super
organism in a sense a collection of
cells that's all connected but we're
always vying for hierarchy and that's
that's real politics right so in in when
i lived in china
one of the things that people would
frequently say to me was you know it's
not that we hate america jack no no no
we don't hate america we just want to be
where america is
we want it to be one was it uh one
chinese yuan equals eight us dollars we
want to be in a situation where we're on
top and you're actually one thing that
uh somebody said to me and i want people
understand he didn't say this as a
threat he doesn't say this offensively
it's just
it was his point of view
it was what he wanted for his country he
said i want to be in a position where
someday
rich chinese families are adopting poor
american children
and that's just how they see it
do you think there's any force in
america at this point that can stand up
to this i mean
fairly certain it's not this
administration like if anything we're
just pushing it all along
well you have a situation in america
right now where there's this idea of
that you know if you go back a couple of
years and i've been i've been sort of
like teasing out this this theory for
the past couple of months now right i
call it the axis of authoritarianism
right so if you go back to the 1990s um
back you know battle of seattle right
antifa is like against globalism and
against china and against all of these
different things and they actually wage
war on the wto
summit there in seattle
her seattle is a large international
port uh because of its proximity to asia
and russia that
they didn't want china into the wto
because they said their their
authoritarianism will come into the
united states and you know it's like you
know you know jack you're like mr
anti-antifa i'm like well there's some
truth
um
i think it's just that antifa got
co-opted but that's a different story um
but
when you see what happened was there is
this idea and
even if you talk to some of the british
interlocutors from the 1980s about the
negotiations over whether or not they
would adhere to the treaty about giving
hong kong port back to china in 1997
which they eventually did one of the
leading theories of the case was that
they would be able
to you they said well we have this this
liberal democracy and we have capitalism
and we have financial capital and these
this free market system and the more
exposure that we can give communist
china to our system it will make them
more open more transparent more
liberalized and eventually make them a
democracy right that's what's going to
happen and this was the whole like if we
go through back to the 90s that's what
everybody talked about when is china
going to become democratic can you look
at
the history of tiananmen square and
certainly you know they had a point
where it seemed like it might be on the
cusp of happening
my theory though is that the opposite
happened because the chinese communist
party went through the tiananmen squares
uh massacre they went through and this
is the key difference between the fall
of communism in the soviet union and
tiananmen in china
in the soviet union in moscow the
soldiers refused to fire on the citizens
when they were protesting they refused
in china
the tanks rolled the tanks
we've all seen it right we don't even
need to go through any more of that and
so this created a situation where the
regime was then able to stay in power
but they also realized that they
couldn't just keep the people in abject
poverty because
this created too much of a mishmash they
were going to have this foreign direct
investment that had been started in the
1970s so what were they to do so they
embark on this new strategy where they
have corporate power
from the west and they have the
authoritarian regime of the of the ccp
on top and so what it created was a situ
a new type of of government that really
hasn't been seen
on on the face of the planet since you
know the time of the great you know
mercantile empires of the past where
they said look there's going to be no
democracy there's going to be pure
authoritarianism but we will allow a
market to operate underneath us as long
as you don't threaten our political
power this is what the ccp became
so american elites when they would go
over american politicians or
congressional delegations and i would
see them when i was in shanghai when
they would come over they would say wow
your guy's system is really good
you don't have to worry about any of
that free speech stuff if you want a
high-speed rail maglev you just knock
down all the houses and what about the
people get rid of them you know move
them away who cares how long they're
live if you're 100 years a thousand
years who cares your village is in my
way oh if you want to build the three
gorgeous damn well just
flood all those towns who cares let's
build a giant lake we need this because
progress is the only thing that matters
to us and so you take those two forms
and put them together it's intoxicating
it is it is a form of absolute power it
is intoxicating and my theory the case
is that in america our elites our ruling
class the one percent whatever you're
gonna call it and if you actually look
at it the one percent of america
it's uh you know that that that phrase
right it used to be in the occupy
movement but the chinese communist party
they're about one percent of the chinese
population as well slightly less um but
i crunched the numbers on it and so it
really is what you have to do is you
have to look away from the elites in
society but if you take you know i guess
you call them the deplorables or just
the american people as a whole the
people that aren't making money that
aren't profiting off this system and you
put them together with in in china the
cognate would be the la baijing which
means the old hundred names you know the
sort of like the same burgeoning middle
class lower class and china they don't
have middle class like we do
you put that together and you say
hey these guys are screwing you
these guys are screwing you they're
robbing you blind right you know they're
all getting rich one side gets the
wealth but the wealth doesn't trickle
down in china because of the
authoritarian system the one side in the
us they're getting the wealth but all
you're all you're becoming is a consumer
right you get your cheap chinese tv your
cheap cell phone whatever it is but you
don't get the wealth right you don't get
any benefits you don't get the jobs you
don't get the secondary tertiary
industries that would come off having a
private primary income driver and this
is why the vast heartland of the united
states has been completely hollowed out
you know i'm from
not the heartland but you know one of
these sort of post-industrial cities in
the northeast and it's the exact same
situation right this is the reason the
rust belt exists is because of this and
it's not elite capture it's not a main
train candidate it's nothing like that
it's a merger that's what i'm trying to
get people understand it's actually a
merger at the highest level
so what do we do
so what do we do good luck with all of
that
you have to decouple right you have to
you have to decouple and you have to say
you have to come to it from a
perspective and i've been i've been
looking at this thing for 15 years right
um i first went to china in
i moved there in 2007 lived there for
two years learned the language from the
military afterwards
primary focus was china um
it it you know it's and i'd be in these
rooms in the intel community and we'd be
talking about like the south china sea
and we'd be talking about oh they're
building these islands and they're
militarizing the islands and they've got
this aircraft carrier and it's going to
be coming in it's going to be doing
operations so what do we do we'll send a
message yeah yeah we'll send a strongly
worded message we'll we'll get the
united nations involved right we'll get
the
three-part talks five-part talks and i
and i would be the the guy in the back
saying you know
i mean that's that's nice but you know i
you know i don't think we're planning to
go to war with china i certainly hope we
aren't but you know unless you use
economic leverage isn't
what they listen it's the only thing
they're going to answer to so
you that's what you have to break up you
have to break up that merger you have to
get people to understand that you are
being screwed that you are being rob
blind and you have to then turn on the
economic screws but i don't care if it's
a republican a democrat or other that
does it right it's just what's good for
the people on both sides of of the the
world in this case both sides of the
pacific it's going to be better if you
break this up you start actually having
real diplomacy and not these these
quasi-transnational organizations
anymore right but is there any chance i
mean that this administration or even if
we got an america a repub american that
was a hell of a freudian slip a
republican administration um is there
any chance that america could actually
do that i mean i certainly don't see it
under biden that we could ever
not no i guess we could do it but that
we would ever exert the type of
influence that you're talking about
i i think it's there i think there's i
think that economic populism is actually
something that you know if you look at
it and going back to what we're just
talking about with the vaccine mandates
you're seeing a lot of this populist
energy find and make strange bedfellows
right look city right now this past
weekend
there was an anti-vaccine march by a
group of maga supporters in staten
island but then there was also an
anti-vaccine protest in brooklyn by
black lives matter and yet if you listen
to some of the things that they were
saying it was almost the exact same
phrases and yet here are two groups that
are supposed to be you know in mortal
opposition to one another and yet
they're both agreed it's that it is and
you know sort of not a you versus we but
it's an us versus it's an up down thing
it's not a left right thing and so i
think the more people
start to talk about economic populism
the less that people talk about some of
these more caustic politicized issues
i actually think that you there are
potentials for a coalition to be built
across
parties across nations of people coming
together and saying look we don't want
to be ruled by a transnational fight you
know elite anymore we just we don't want
it we want to be countries again we want
to be citizens again we want to have
real diplomacy um you're france you know
france is is standing up right now and
kind of
thumbing their nose at uh
at biden they pulled their ambassador
which is like the first time in history
that i think that's ever done and i
think that's it in a sense i think it's
good because
as the u.s you know because the u.s is
losing
its its position right it's certainly
losing its position as the global
hegemon if you will
then
uh it's going to require alliances and
it's going to require
actual diplomacy and sitting down with
people that we want to have actual help
with and mutual aid do you you can't
have any more of this you know we're
going to invade iraq and you have to
come along because we said so right or
else we're going to pull this that and
that everything no no we're not going to
do that anymore it has to be actual
mutually assured benefit we always talk
about we just for destruction why don't
we talk about mutually short benefit
right so what do you think that actually
looks like from an american perspective
like i've been saying for a while as a
kind of new guy to the to the right if
that if we can talk about things in that
left-right paradigm but i get it it's
top-down really or authoritarian liberty
it shoved you out yeah right right or
they shut me out but for this new thing
the center-right sort of economic
populist thing that you're talking about
like i see myself on more of say like a
libertarian side of that then there are
sort of more traditional religious
conservatives i think we're seeing tulsi
gabbard kind of yeah but look we're
obviously on the same side in the big
picture of things i see someone like
tulsi gabbard being like well there's
nothing left for me over here i don't
know that she's fully making the move
but it seems like she's on her way i see
that thing as as super broad i i think
that the the disagreements that we might
have can all be sort of worked on or
like we still want to live in the same
country with each other what do you
think that really looks like politically
like is it trump that has to lead that
thing in because he kind of was the guy
that was doing it in the first place uh
or or has that ship sailed like what
does it actually look like
yeah it's it
that's the thing with movements right is
that movements are great but ideologies
suck right so you know movements are
wonderful because they're they're
explosive they're natural they're living
organisms of their own but then ideology
gets injected and people try to codify
it and people try to to quantify it and
package it and sell it and all this
stuff and that it's it it always sort of
takes away from that spirit of it um you
saw this in the spirit of of 2016 where
it was just this this movement this
explosion of memes and energy and all
things across the place but i really do
think that that a lot of that energy is
there it's just moved and you know i i
do think that the trump movement is part
of it um you can't and you can't remove
trump from the trump movement right you
just you just can't i know there's so
many people who are like oh man i just
wish he would you know sit out 24 and
let desantis take his turn
it's probably not going to happen it's
probably he's probably going to run just
give him yeah you've been saying that
and i'm i'm hearing from every somewhat
insider that i know that he's running
yeah i mean look
he's the kind of guy just just
understand the psychology right he's the
kind of guy where
if
you know if he thought
and again i'm not saying this is what
happened i'm saying just talking his
perspective if he thought he'd be beaten
fair and square he'd say all right and
he'd you know he'd pack up we'd go home
but if he thought something was stolen
from him
right if he thought something was taken
away from him then does he really seem
like the kind of guy that's just going
to let that happen this is going to let
that slide of course not no he's going
to be the guy who's going to want to get
back in and take back what he
in you know right or wrong views as
something that is rightfully his and i
think that why wouldn't he think they'd
just do it again though
if that's what he believes i think that
is what he believes like why wouldn't he
think has he done any of the lead leg
work to fix the system that you know he
feels wrong to him in the first place i
think you see i do think you see some
laws getting passed in in 2022 and and
really when it comes down to it there
were so many things that happened on the
back of kovid that i don't think are
going to be sustainable i think that was
something and you're seeing a lot of it
you know attempt to be
continued but i think that a lot of
these sort of you know temporary
measures that were that were held are
not going to face the same type of
scrutiny because you really do see
people that are very upset with it you
see people saying look this just doesn't
feel transparent it doesn't feel like
the same type of system that we've had
in the past and they want to go back to
it so they're looking to their governors
particularly you know look at georgia
the amount of crap they went through
when they passed that law and i know i
know trump doesn't like kemp very much
but you gotta admit that was a pretty
good law if you're you know from his
perspective he he did deliver something
that you know you should support if you
are you know someone who is coming from
that side um now that being said
i i'm personally somebody who i say look
you know talking about the french let's
take the french example and what's the
what do the french do they use voter id
they use voting in person unless you
have a met a specific medical reason
like you literally can't leave your
house right other than that you're
you're voting in person and you're
voting with voter id i think that's
great i think that's fantastic we need
to know who's voting it's it's a basic
system of democracy and something also
by the way where i was i was actually
talking to a french mep last um last
week he was telling me they know the
answers to their election they have the
outcome within like two hours after the
poll club the entire country and they
look at the united states what are you
guys doing like what are you doing what
is this and so it's ridiculous so i do
think that there are methods that you
know going back to sort of my my read on
trump that there are things that he can
put in place and certainly you know
obviously there are certain states like
like california like you know they worry
about that like you're not going to win
california there donald trump
um
maybe virginia's in that bucket as well
i know some republicans aren't gonna be
mad that i say that but i don't know if
virginia is possible to win bar
republican anymore but by the same token
i don't know that florida is a swing
state anymore
you look at the past few elections the
way the population's been moving the way
a lot of people you know hispanics in
florida broke for trump uh broke really
big for trump um not not i don't mean
majority but in in a way that we haven't
seen in the past
and so i i think that there's a
coalition
for at least a trump or a trump style
candidate in florida that would be
pretty solidly read um so there's
there's absolutely a pathway forward for
that and you know
like it or not you know just as from
from an analyst perspective you know
he's definitely going to run the real
question though is and i see nobody
talking about this is that if let's say
trump runs and wins right
and just what if what if he runs and
wins he can only do one more turn right
he can only do one more term so he's out
so whoever he picks as vice president
then if he runs and wins
is really going to be set up is really
going to be set up to sort of be the
um you know be the inheritor of this
movement whatever this thing is so when
i look at this whole thing i almost
think you're gonna it's it's almost like
a passing of the baton kind of thing and
that whoever that pick is and and really
i've been thinking about it tulsi was
someone that i did kind of have in mind
because i think that's a really
interesting choice and i think that she
um embodies a lot of the spirit in many
ways but i'm not i'm not 100 sold on on
her either though i will say that tulsi
is somebody that uh i had respect for
even
even years ago 2014 i was out in hawaii
and i actually went and i was on there
for a military thing and i um
actually went and stopped by her office
and was just talking to her staff got to
meet her her mom was there you know
because she was just someone that even
as a democrat because of where she was
on at the time military issues someone
that i had a lot of respect for
are there any same democrats left at
this point i mean mainstream i don't
mean the average person of course
there's some sane democrats but like in
terms of the machinery that is the
democratic party are there any
the the former me's are there any of
them left over there that can be worked
with
well i think there are but i think it's
going to be on an issue by issue basis
right you know i think you i think you
do see democrats
by and large who have good outlooks when
it comes to social media right i'm
talking about actually using the
government to rein in the power of
social media and these these oligarchic
systems but the only problem is of
course they
where we disagree is that they say well
not only should we reign in the power
but also you have to crack down on that
very bad misinformation and the very bad
you know these people are saying that
hunter biden had a laptop and kovit
might have come from a lab and they
might have been doing function
experiments these crazy crazy statements
or saying things like americans might be
left behind in afghanistan just just
wild wild you know
tin foil stuff uh when of course we all
know the truth of all that and so
i think there but i do think there's
room there i do think that's a that's a
broad movement and a broad issue topic
where i think you could actually sit
down and find some common ground um
i actually did i hate to say it but you
know again i i actually respected the
way that when amazon was trying to come
into aoc's district aoc was like no just
just you're going to ruin this area
you're going to you're going to kick out
all the people you're going to destroy
all of it um though i do
also point out that she's a hypocrite
because in and she very famously is in
navy yard in dc and that's exactly what
happened in navy yards that all the
people came from the hill kicked out the
families that have been living there for
generations they're now over in pg
county maryland and now you've got all
like you know the dc yuppies are based
and like are all living around navy yard
it is the worst place in dc i i cannot
stand it down like i'm a people watcher
i like people watching not in navy yard
oh my gosh i was there the other day i i
like i almost had like i had to leave i
actually like the toxic
just just energy of that place oh
disgusting
where does uh the mainstream media or
whatever is left of it where does that
fit in this whole equation you know i
did my show this morning and just once
again
just showing clips of cnn saying the
comp you know stelter usually saying
just the reverse of everything he said a
year ago under trump and just the
endless lies and how that we're all just
being shifted into our own little worlds
where we just believe completely
different things is there anything that
can be done to fix this
dinosaur that's that's the dinosaur
right you know they they are going to go
the way i don't know if there'll be a
comet but we'll def we are seeing an
evolution
right now in terms of media we're seeing
a massive explosion in terms of of media
social media has given people the
opportunity
to use these systems to create a real
democratization of information in a way
that's never before been seen
never before been seen and that's of
course why they want to shut it all down
like these narrative gatekeepers and so
i don't foresee us like i don't know
anybody under 40 who just
goes home and sits down and turns on
cable news the way they used to right i
know people say i'm going to watch this
specific show and then i'm going to
catch this podcast when i'm at the gym
and i'm going to listen to this audio
book and oh i love listening to human
events daily from from poso in in the
evening uh right before i go to bed on
my my pillow which is available at
mypillar.com
had to do it i knew it was coming
but but no i really do think that people
are going to follow less and less brands
and they're going to follow more and
more individuals and i really think
that's the way coming forward
when you look at joe rogan as sort of
the
uh very much a pioneer in this sense
rush limbaugh in many ways a pioneer in
this sense not necessarily in terms of
obviously they have a lot of stuff i'm
sure they disagree on but the idea that
i'm going to tune in because i don't
always agree with this guy
but i like him
i think he's personable i like what he
has to say i like that he's upfront
about where he's coming from and i don't
think that they're trying to mislead me
and at the end of the day i think that's
what anybody wants and i think that
corporate america and specifically
corporate media has lost that they've
totally lost that sense of it um
you know we did there was a sort of
hagiography
of the 911 anchors i don't know if you
saw any of that because they just had
the 20th anniversary and all the anchors
were you know and brokaw and jennings
and and rather they were the ones that
that walked us through that's the person
i don't really remember um them being
the ones who walked us through but that
was like the last shining moment where
you really only had three choices for
your media and now it's totally
dispersed and it ain't going back it
that genie ain't going back in the
bottle the toothpaste ain't going back
in the tube the bell cannot be unrung
right you are going to have now a
bifurcated media you're going so does
that lead to parallel economies does
that lead to parallel systems that lead
to parallel countries i hope not i
really really really hope not because i
really don't want to do that um so
that's why i've always been trying to
set
you know basic guidelines the new yorker
just ran a piece
yesterday uh
yeah yesterday that we call for sabotage
and the bombing and and blowing up
pipelines i said look you have to put a
fault line on no doxxing right no going
after families and no violence it's
simple no violence you lay down some of
those guard rails at least so at least
you know if we're going to have these
culture wars right we don't want to blow
up the entire country while we're at it
but but is that the inherent problem i
mean i've discussed this with tucker and
a bunch of other people that they
actually believe you should do those
things and that political violence is
okay and maybe if you have to take out a
couple bloggers like they would do in
bangladesh or pakistan that's kind of
okay we can blow up i mean this this
headline from it was new yorker or new
york yeah new yorker right new york yeah
i mean literally we're gonna we can blow
things up like maybe we have to like
we have rules they don't this is a
asymmetric problem
well see that and that that comes down
to a larger question of the rule of law
right so will will
were the laws applied equally to you
know and i'm not someone who says i i
defend what happened on january 6 but i
do like i do look at it from perspective
of saying were the laws applied to the
january 6 rioters the same way they were
applied to the antifa rioters of 2020
right
was it applied at the same level or to
the people that attacked trump's
inauguration in 2017 in washington dc
right in many cases on some of the same
streets right where it took place so we
can see obviously not and the aclu came
in and the city of washington dc had to
pay a 1.2 million dollar sediment to
the the 200 antifa that were arrested on
mass because of uh false targeting and
all this other junk this settlement with
them and so
that's the problem of the system that
we're in and so what i what i try to do
is i turn this around and i say look if
if you are on the right or if you're
someone who's the victim of this you
have to prosecute and if you can't
prosecute you have to sue and you have
to stand up and you have to do it now
that's why anybody who's taken a swing
at me or there's that that picture of me
and the uh the antifa guy i i'm taking a
court i will testify i will press
charges every single time if you can't
be identified and guess what we are
going to identify you we're going to put
you behind bars if you're lying you're
screaming you're doing you know
defamation will bring charges against
you right you have to use the system of
law and peaceful civil disobedience
right the same way that i see people
saying like i refuse you know zero
defuse right uh in terms of these
vaccine mandates because that's the only
way that people on mass are going to be
able to say no we check out
what else is on your mind these days
besides all of this
on my mind i don't know i've been um
i want to write a historical fiction
novel or possibly comic book series
about washington dc i've been uh i've
actually been thinking about that lately
um there's this there's this whole idea
that washington dc has always been this
like you know pristine capital but there
is actually like in the post-civil war
era there's been a there was a huge
um
just just seedy underbelly of washington
but right in between where
the white house is ensconced and the
capital building and there's there's a
canal there used to be a canal actually
because that was sort of the main
thoroughfare in the past that connected
the potomac river to the us capital and
so the senators the congressman would go
back and forth
and
um so it's it's kind of where the
national mall is now it's all it's all
you know um covered up now but back in
the day that era used to be so bad
and the soldiers the union soldiers in
the civil war would go in there and
there was it was saloons and like
uh
uh you know like like brothels and just
just craziness
and it was so bad that people would go
in there and like they would just find
dead bodies floating around in this
canal all the time and so
one of the things that that they started
referring to the place was was murder
bay
and i just thought man it's it was a
swamp and then it was murder bay and now
it's washington dc and if people want to
actually understand the history the real
history of what happens in our nation's
capital we have to actually start
telling these stories so that's that's
one thing i'm looking at because again
you know you know you talk about
look the daily stuff and the china stuff
and all that like that's that's that's
my drive that's doing the show
you know this is the human events daily
studio we just partnered with turning
point usa we're doing this now every day
we went number one uh for the first two
weeks that we're out was amazing for
apple politics and um it's
for that one i keep it short it's like
25 minutes
i call it the bottom line up front be
good be brief be gone right
um and it's like something you can just
share with your normies a couple of
stories a day but i i really want to
keep going with this cultural stuff you
can you know you can kind of see i have
um you know i have a lot of passion for
it i have a lot of interest for it and i
think that ultimately
certain
the daily stuff has a shelf life right
you know listen you hear one of these
things even this conversation that you
and i are having it's you know maybe
relevant for like a couple of weeks and
then it's gone right but if you have a
cultural product you have artwork if you
have something that you're putting real
value into and that is also uh has an
exegesis of
you know timeless values really then
that's something that you can look back
30 years and say you know what it's
still
there's a reason that we read certain
books over and over there's a reason
that certain um
you know certain collections of books
have gone down through the ages and you
know i'm not saying that you know i'm
going to write something like that but
uh you know i do think that i do think
that that stuff
long term speaking is actually has a lot
of value
i'm with you man build new things
write new books and
although we will link
to the book down below i will give you a
chance one more time if you want to very
cleanly and clearly sell a pillow right
now we can go out on that note dave i i
don't know
you know i know you travel a lot in your
business i know there's there's so much
you do everybody in the world's like i
want dave rubin how do i get dave rubin
well you got to travel here you got to
travel there
the only way to do all that travel is if
you get the best night's sleep in the
whole wide world
by utilizing
promo code posto for up to 66 off at
mypillow.com actually the towels just
came back in and people are telling me
they really love the towel packs i don't
have one yet though
talk to my wife that she said i told her
i'd order it and i haven't i haven't
actually done it yet
author podcaster pillow salesman just
incredible all right poco i'll see you
soon thanks man appreciate it dave thank
you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell